[Arabic recitation]
We have a narration here
which has been collected on the
authority of
reported by
on the authority of
which we hear mentions in the book of
knowledge
which we've been reading for quite a
while now. In the vein of the virtue of
knowledge, the virtue of seeking
knowledge, the virtue of the people of
knowledge and the dangers of ignorance
or seeking knowledge for ignorant
reasons. This is another point that he
will come to inshallah. This particular
narration
he mentions that our messenger
sallall.aii wasallam said
that no believer
will ever have his fill of good
until he has finally arrived at
paradise.
No believer will ever be satisfied, will
ever have his fill of good until his
final arrival is in paradise. This is
the only thing that will suffice him.
Now
in order to understand this narration in
the spirit in which it was intended,
it's important for us to understand
something about the human nature and the
way that the commands of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
do not go against necessarily that human
nature, but rather harness that human
nature. You and I, every human being, we
all have proclivities. We all have
things that we tend towards. We all have
what you would say impulses. We all
have driving forces that bite at our
heels and tend us forward in different
ways. We just heard in the tonight
[Silence]
We just heard in the verses tonight of
surah in our prayer that Allah tells us
and for each individual his direction
that he is most prone to. So race and
hasten to good deeds, Allah has made
good at every direction you can take in
this world. Just there is bad at
every direction, there is good, there is
potential at every direction. You have
driving forces, I have driving forces.
You have things that urge you forward
and I have things that urge me forward.
If we all had the same urges and we were
all urged towards the same common goals
then society would not be able to
function. This world would fall apart.
The idea that we have here in the
west is that everyone needs to be a CEO.
Okay? Everyone needs to be the company
manager. Everyone needs to be the
president, the big shot, the main
character, the tough guy in the room.
Everybody needs to be number one.
This is a farce.
Allah has made it that there are people
who do not want actively do not want to
be in those positions. They actively
seek positions of subordination.
And there are people who actively seek
positions of leadership.
And alhamdulillah that is the way
because this is how the world will
function. You can meet a garbage man,
you can meet a seamstress, you can meet
a janitor, someone that in this society
is considered to be a lowly job. We know
there is no such thing as a lowly job.
All jobs need to be done. But what is
considered to be a lowly job, you will
meet many of them who not only are
content in what they do, but they
wouldn't have it any other way. They
it just as it is. And that's not
because they don't have drive. It's
because they have different
proclivities. They have different
driving forces. You cannot stop
a human being's driving force. And
he tells us that trying to take on an
urge, a human being's urge, a force,
trying to take it on directly is like
trying to build a dam that has no outlet
for the water to go. What will
eventually happen?
It will crash through. There is no dam
big enough nor strong enough that can
ever stop even the smallest of flowing
rivers completely. It has to have an
outlet.
So he tells us that the commandments of
the Quran and Sunnah they do not ever
try to stop and cut off something that
is a natural force in the human being.
Whether that's creativity, whether that
is drive, whether that is rather it
harnesses and redirects.
That's why there's no celibacy in Islam.
It is actively haram
to refrain from marriage, to go out of
your way to refrain from marriage and to
be celibate. Why? Because that is a
driving force of human nature to want to
have love and to want to reproduce. And
if you try to stop that unnaturally
bad things come. What have we seen from
celibacy in our modern world and even in
ancient world? Things pedophilia,
things homosexuality,
things extreme sexual perversion.
Why? because you are meddling with the
forces that Allah has constructed in the
human being. The commandments of the
Quran don't ever try to dam up a flowing
river in human being. It always what
redirects it. The human being in this
narration we have an appetite. Human
beings we have an appetite.
What does Allah tell us about this
appetite? The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says
[Silence]
He tells us that if a a human being had
an entire valley of gold, eventually
he'd wish he had two. And if he had two,
he wish he had the third. The human
being's mouth and stomach will never be
filled except by dirt, meaning at death.
That is the only time he will become
satisfied. So what does Allah give us?
He gives us a way to redirect.
Redirect the appetite to the hereafter.
Redirect that appetite. Don't try to cut
it off. Don't starve it. Because when
you starve a natural force in the human
being, it comes back with a vengeance.
Don't starve it. Redirect it.
Redirect it towards that which is
productive, that which is good for the
hereafter.
And that is found in knowledge. And that
is found in the struggle of jihad. for
men and for women it is found in Omrah
it is found in her marriage with her
husband and you know in in the west now
it's shameful for a woman to be
sufficed by just having a family like
you're just a breeding factory right and
you're just some man's play thing neo
feminism has absolutely rotted an entire
generation's brain
however Ever this is what Allah has
created the human being as you try to
change that nature it will bite you back
with a vengeance
says
[Silence]
he says
that the man
was created from where? From the earth.
And so he will always find his
fulfillment in the earth.
And a woman was created from what?
From what? A man. And so she will always
find her fulfillment where? In a man.
And it's good that he created them that
way. Could you imagine if all men and
women were exactly the same? It would be
a nightmare. It would be a disaster. We
wouldn't even be able to get along as
roommates. How many grown men do you
know that live with other grown men as
roommates long-term,
very rare, and they're very strange
folks usually. Or they're here on some
kind of mission.
Two men living together in a house, two
independents having their domain.
Impossible. They will clash.
Allah created them that way. That's how
they've been created. And a woman has
been created to fit into that. This is
how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made us.
If you try to ch if you try to mar
that or build a dam on that force, it
will break the dam and it will destroy
[Arabic recitation]
That's fine. You could set that chair
back up on